foreign
investigation into East Kent maternity
services
I'd like to
um
tell you briefly about the findings and
about what I want to see happen next
um I've just come from a meeting with
families who've been affected by this
and my colleagues on the panel have
remained there to to help as far as they
can I can tell you there is a great deal
of emotion and a substantial amount of
anger at what people have heard this
morning and what they're now reading
it's been a great privilege to be asked
to do this investigation
it's been a privilege to work with such
an excellent panel and Secretariat and
to have the help of so many families
that we have met and who have
given of themselves to help us
understand what has happened at Great
cost in many cases it's also been a
frustration
when I reported on East on beg your
pardon at morecon Bay maternity services
in 2015 I did not imagine that I would
be back reporting on a similar set of
circumstances seven years later
let alone that there would have been
another two major maternity failures in
the meantime
and I want to say at the outset that
this cannot go on we cannot go on
treating each individual service failure
as though it's a one-off never to be
repeated isolated failure because
experience says if that's what we do
it'll pop up again somewhere else in the
time to come and I do not want to be in
the position ever again of having some
families who have been harmed telling us
about service failures that the NHS
should have known about first and did
not
carrying out the investigation
I've kept that in mind as much as but
not more than what has actually happened
in East Kent
what has happened in this case is
deplorable and harrowing we have
numerous instances of care that was not
given to the right standards
consistently failed to meet standards
with deaths and significant harm in
schools for the families
they had 202 families that came forward
in 97 deaths injuries or other harm
could have been different if care had
been given to the standards accepted
National
in 45 of the 65 stillborn and newborn
babies who died
they could have had a different outcome
had care been given to the standards
accepted accepted National
as well as that we found that there had
been frequent instances where
significant harm was caused to people's
well-being
by the unkind and callous way and
occasions that they were treated and
some have been deeply affected by that
many have been deeply affected by that
we haven't found that there's been a
single clinical cause of the failure
what we've found is four underlying
themes that led directly to these
problems
the first is Extreme failures of
teamworking as you know maternity care
has to be delivered by groups of
professionals working together from
different backgrounds from different
professions they have to work together
effectively they did not and there are
various reasons for that including lack
of trust and lack of respect but there
is also inescapably the fact that
professionals can sometimes
get the impression that they're working
to different goals
it might be to reduce the amount of
intervention or it might be to not
reduce the amount of intervention a team
that works to different goals in my view
is not a team
secondly failures of professionalism of
compassion and of kindness people were
dealt with
rudely
arrogantly and with hostility and you'll
find numerous examples
in the report women were not listened to
they reported
a range of things that should have been
listened to for example that they were
in labor for example that their
membranes had ruptured for example that
the baby's movements had altered and
they were disregarded and that led
directly to instances of
the same failures of compassion and
listening happened after devastating
outcomes such as the death of a baby
people were treated
with dismissiveness and denial
not only does that cause people deep
distress it also prevents learning so
that the same set of mistakes kept
happening over again because people were
not properly looking and learning
on at least eight separate occasions
over a 10-year period the trust board
was presented with what should have been
inescapable signals but there were
serious problems in the maternity unit
they could have acknowledged that they
could have investigated they could have
put it out that started in 2010 the
first instance was in 2010.
but they didn't in every single case
they found a way to deny that there were
problems to disregard to say that on the
whole Services were okay or at least
good enough and they were wrong to do
that as a result of that the pattern of
behavior and of harm continued unaltered
through the entire period of the
investigation until the end of 2020 it
need not have happened like not
what do we do in previous investigations
including my own
we have sought to set out detailed
operational recommendations to change
this do that don't do that
I think the time has passed to do that
we cannot pretend that this works any
longer all that happens is we have
another instance of the same problem
cropping up again
as a result of that I've not sought to
set out detailed operational
recommendations I have identified four
major underlying areas that need to be
acted on and they need other people I
can't do it as an independent
investigation but they need the
leadership of the Health Service they
need ministers they need NHS England
to act on these four areas otherwise I
very much fear that we will all be back
probably not me but you all will be back
somewhere else in a year or Tuesday
the four areas
firstly we have to find a way to detect
dysfunctional units as they're beginning
to slide not after they have
reduced
to the point where you have families
coming along and saying that things have
gone wrong with Services we should never
again be in a position we have to have a
mechanism I'm proposing a way to do that
through something I would call a
maternity signaling system which takes
the information we largely have
and which shows shows women it shows
clinicians it shows trusts and it shows
NHS England where people stand on their
outcomes and on their safety and which
direction they're trending and whether
the variations from month to month are
random or whether they're systematic in
their thought there is a need to look if
we'd had a system like that in 2010 I
believe that the problems would have
been inescapable then it's beyond time
that we had one and I think we must work
hard
um
secondly I think we have to address the
problems of inappropriate and uncaring
behavior that cropped up time and again
we heard so many accounts of it
I understand of course the NH NHS staff
are operating under strain at the moment
I absolutely appreciate that
that is not an excuse for uncaring rude
or aggressive behavior which is what we
found and we do not believe that this is
entirely restricted to East Kent that
would be a dangerous assumption
third I think we must have a coherent
basis for teamwork in maternity
maternity is
like all clinical Specialties dependent
on
multi-professional groups working
together in a coherent team it's
probably more dependent on that than
some other Specialties and yet the
challenges appear to be greater in
maternity I can't escape the fact that
some of that is about people picking up
mixed messages about what their
objectives are are they there to reduce
the amount of intervention or are they
there to continue with the same amount
of intervention or to do more
intervention you can't have a team that
functions with different objectives and
finally I think we have to address the
problem of trusts responding to
legitimate inquiries and questions with
deflection and denial they do this in
the name of reputation management It's a
cruel practice that ends up with
families such as the ones that I've just
been talking to being denied the truth
that's a terrible thing to do to
somebody on the name of protecting your
reputation
I think that the current incentives for
trusts clearly don't dissuade them from
doing this because it is the standard
response
and there has to be a better mechanism
to make sure that they don't do that I
think that I would and I do recommend a
statutory provision for this it's been
called the Hillsborough law in the past
but it would place if enacted it would
place a statutory Duty a legal Duty on
public bodies to be truthful and not to
conceal problems
the findings of the investigation are
Stark and the conclusions are shocking
and uncomfortable
I thank everybody who has helped us that
includes the staff of the trust but most
of all the families who gave up their
time and a lot of themselves to help us
understand what had happened we owe it
to all of them to listen to take very
seriously what has happened and to
address the areas that have been set out
to make sure
for the sake of services in East Kent
and wider that these problems are
eradicated thank you I'm happy to take
questions that you might have at the
moment
keep going until
start with Michael Buchanan for BBC
um
thank you hi Michael Buchanan BBC News
you see that you could you were unable
to detect any discernible Improvement
and outcomes throughout your the 11
years of care that you are looking at
given that
what would what would be your advice to
a pregnant woman in this area today
who's maybe having to go into one of
these hospitals for the next couple of
weeks
I would say know the questions that you
want to ask and make sure that you get
the answers to them I know that we ended
our period of Investigation at the end
of 2020 I know that since then that has
been a lot of work with a Improvement
team of expert Obstetricians and
midwives going into East Kent it's been
provided by NHS England it's essential
that continues I think that seeing so
starkly set out the problems that they
need to address will help greatly with
that process but I don't I'm not in a
position to report on what the services
are like as of today I think know the
questions that you want to ask and make
sure that you ask don't be a bashed
about asking questions
kit Bradshaw
um you say the trust failed to read the
signals throughout the time you looked
at as you've just been explaining and
the cycle of failure continued
including under the current chief
executive is there an issue with the
size of the trust or how the management
currently works that needs to change in
your view
we had a look at
look at the external constraints that
people were Keen to point out to us and
they said there's problems of geography
uh you know that the amount of C that
surrounds the trust there are problems
of recruiting staff there are problems
of physical infrastructure in the trust
and I recognize all of those problems I
do not find that they are sufficient to
explain or to excuse the problems that
happened I think rather they've been a
shield to fall back on to not address
some of the problems that really needed
to be addressed and just on the
deflection point that you said what do
you make of the fact the chief executive
is not doing any interviews or speaking
to the media today
I would uh suggest that the trust has to
be accountable for all of this we've
said in a report that accountability
lies with the trust board I can
understand that they might want some
time to actually digest what's in the
report there is a substantial amount of
evidence in there and they'll want to
digest all of that I think that what
I've found in my experience is that when
trusts are able to do that and fully
acknowledge the reality of what they've
been presiding over for the last 13
years that's the starting point of the
change that badly needs to happen
options
uh Dr kirka you talk about the culture
of denial and deflection is there
anything that makes you think that
perhaps there could have been something
even worse I.E an attempt to disguise or
to cover up the truth and secondly the
the number of families you spoke of 202
families but you alluded to possibly
many more is there ever going to be
a way of knowing exactly how many
families might have been affected by
this Scandal okay we gave people the
opportunity to come forward and we
encouraged people and we made it as easy
as possible to come forward absolutely
understand that not everybody wants to
do that everybody has to deal with these
things in their own way and I didn't
want
to go looking to give people information
they might not have wanted we took the
decision when we had 202 families had
responded to my requests to come forward
that we had sufficient evidence to work
out what the problems were I'm
absolutely sure of that today and
therefore we didn't want to prolong the
process any further to seek whether
there might have been any other people
I've offered each one of those families
the opportunity to come and talk to me
on an individual basis about what the
findings were in their particular case
obviously I can't go into that before
that but they do have the opportunity to
find that out
um the culture of denial
um we looked carefully to see whether
there was any evidence of conscious
collusion to do that we didn't find any
um
all I can say is that
their interests all aligned with telling
people as little as possible and with
saying things that would deflect from
the problems and with not giving people
the truth about what had happened there
are numerous examples in the report I
don't have evidence to say exactly how
they came to that or whether it was
simply a coincidence of their interest
Mark woman
hello Dr kokup thank you
um
this trust has had Untold interventions
during the time scale you were looking
at not just since 2020 Department of
Health nhsc CQC maternity Improvement
programs in 2017 they were described in
their own maternity Department as one of
the system is one of the best in the
country
how on Earth
are people supposed to understand what's
going on when even the national bodies
that are sent in with Improvement
directors to look at it and understand
it and change it aren't doing their job
apparently
yeah
um
I think that's
a very important part of why I want to
make systems to detect trusts that are
getting into difficulties
um
Point them out to show where they are
without relying on voluntary disclosure
of things
I think we all know that there is an
industry in many trusts when there's a
CQC inspection of how do we put the best
face on everything there are people
employed literally to demonstrate the
best face to this eqc it's a problem we
have to stop trusts behaving like that
that's why I referred to the public
disclosure bill that I would like to see
be reinstituted and I would like this
maternity signaling system whatever you
end up calling it to be showing people
objectively not on the basis of how many
incidents they report because we all
know that incidents don't get reported
sometimes and there are numerous
examples of that in this kit and I want
it to be based on objective evidence
that shows you whatever the intention of
the their trust is
lower quantity
thank you
and could you clarify please whether 45
babies could have or should have lived
there were 45 where if of 65 where if
care had been given to the nationally
accepted standards the outcome could
have been different
and are you confident that this won't
happen again or do you think that change
will happen and systems will be put in
place to prevent this happening again
I've just come from a meeting with the
families where they vary vehemently and
very emotionally understandably asked
exactly the same question all I can say
is my job as an independent investigator
is to set it all out and to say where I
think the problems lie I have to
understand that it's for others it's for
ministers the Department of Health it's
for NHS England who have the statutory
levers to implement change I would like
to be involved in that process I have
established a dialogue with ministers
and with NHS England I stand ready to be
involved in that if I must
thank you
Alex G
hello everyone and the Hayward
um when would you like to see the
maternity signaling system set up do you
think that could be done in the next few
weeks or months
I think it'll take longer than a few
weeks I would hope that we would be
talking about a period of
you know I don't know it's hard to put a
label on it at this stage but months
rather than weeks for sure there's a
there's a there are some technical
problems to be overcome because of the
nature of maternity
a lot of people have good outcomes
regardless but that is a problem that
outcomes are horrific when it goes wrong
and and we have to avoid those to the
nth degree as far as we possibly can but
looking at the raw data you have these
problems to overcome that you know 96
are going to be okay regardless so I
don't want to pretend that it's simple
it's not these are complex problems it's
doable I'm sure that it's doable it has
been done in other fields for sure but
it will take a little while it's it's
not tomorrow
some Blanchard
thank you
um it's obviously quite vast and
wide-ranging report I just wonder if you
could say a bit about which aspects of
it troubled you the most personally and
how it compared to what you expected
when you began
I didn't have any expectations when I
began I think it's very important to say
that we were independent and we were
objective we did not start out with
preconceived notions
that survived meeting about half a dozen
families but that's how we started out
anyway
um what troubles me the most is uh the
attitudes and behavior that dismissed
women who had legitimate complaints and
legitimate questions and that meant that
learning did not happen
clinical error happens everywhere it's a
feature of every Healthcare System and I
don't want to do anything that would
discourage people from reporting error I
want people to report errors more often
and I want them to feel free from doing
that that is correct and people should
not be pursued for having reported
clinical errors but when people deny the
truth and when people refuse to tell
people
information that they are not you know
they're not just entitled to it they
deserve to know what happened when
something's gone wrong and when that
then in turn stops them investigating
and they make the same mistakes over and
over again and I have no sympathy at all
I find that shocking and I would wish
that that would change
hi it's peers hotcake BBC Southeast
how quickly and how urgently do we need
to see change and how much Faith do you
have that that will happen
we need to see change absolutely as
rapidly as it can be done there's no
excuse for delay we know what the
problems are we have to address them it
will take some time as I was explaining
in the context of the mythology
signaling system because it's no good
rushing it and coming out with a product
that doesn't work we have to do the
right thing and it will take a little
time but we have to start now
um my job now I think having presented
the report and made what needs to happen
I hope inescapably clear is to make sure
that I keep on saying that and I do
intend to do that I don't want to get on
the train back to gateshead tonight and
that's the end of it I don't look at it
in that way I want to continue with this
world
okay pickles
hello
um obviously a lot of what you've said
refers to uncaring behavior in a
profession that you'd expect to have the
most caring people
um going into it I just wondered what
you think's happened to it as a service
in general yeah
I think that's a really good question I
think it's really difficult it's
difficult for
Professionals for doctors and and
midwives who've worked all their lives
to not be like that to understand how
people can let themselves go to that
extent it was hard for us hard to
comprehend
what I think happens is this is not
taught in a collection in a classroom or
a lecture theater I'm sure of that
people are getting the right messages
about how to how to behave but I think
that there are places where what you see
from people in senior positions in your
profession and in other professions
is different and you see uncaring
behavior and that becomes accepted it
becomes normalized that's how we do
things around here
um and if you have quite an isolated
Community then Margate is clinically
quite isolated even Ashford is there's
not that much interchange in and out
it's possible for standards to slip an
awful long way before anybody realizes
what the heck's happened because you're
not getting that external scrutiny
people can't see it people did see some
of it in these can people said things to
us like you know it was the worst trust
behavior that we'd ever seen
but unfortunately within the trust they
hadn't they wouldn't accept that what I
want them to do as a result of reading
this report is to say yes it really was
that bad and we had to stop doing that
Tom pew
of just the scale of the channels that
trust faces now
yeah the problems are clearly not
superficial they're clearly deep rooted
and that isn't easy to change
but my experience has been that actually
once you confront everybody with it
inescapable evidence of the reality of
it they do change that's what I've found
so far and I want to assume you know I
don't want to assume I want to
be optimistic and say that's what's
going to happen in East County but there
has to be scrutiny there has to be a
process to make sure that it does happen
in the case of Eastern as it has
happened elsewhere
I really do think that the process
starts today
thank you um the trust had been asked to
improve on numerous occasions did you
look at or even consider whether the
services in Kent should actually
continue or did you consider shutting
them down
[Music]
um
shutting down a service
is a very very drastic thing to do if
the capacity isn't there for people to
go elsewhere or if it faces them with
terrible Journeys I mean the objective
has to be you're going to provide a
service provide it properly I don't
think it's
helpful to women to be told that there
simply isn't any obstetric care between
mainston and the sea
but I do think it's important that they
do change
between my gold
thank you Victoria McDonald from Channel
4 News
um firstly have there been any referrals
or should there be any referrals to the
General Medical Council or the nursing
and Midwifery Council or should there or
have there been any resignations as a
result of your report and secondly
you there was a palpable sense of
frustration that you were there at
Morgan Bay and you are here now can you
think of something that you said should
be done at Morgan Bay that should have
been done that wasn't that has led to
this I said all of the things about team
working and caring in relation to
Morecambe I said that the worst thing
that you can hear in a hospital is don't
worry it could never happen here what's
happened is numerous examples of it
exactly happening here because people
don't look at
other places and say that might be us
East Kent specifically commissioned a an
external report are we another more
convey and the answer was a resounding
no we're not unbelievable to me and an
extraordinary there's some people still
thought so
um
has it changed
in the meantime have other things
happened have there been other bits of
process like the professional Regulators
not yet because of fundamental plank of
our investigation was that we would tell
the families first what the findings
were and I've literally just come from
the meeting where I have done that
partly remotely and partly to people in
the room
um
they're copies of the report will go to
all of the bodies that you would expect
it to and it will also go to the
professional Regulators they will look
at it very carefully and should they
want to ask me about what the evidence
was that lay behind some of these things
and of course I am ready to help
behavioral Morris
um
Rebecca Thomas
thanks Bill hi Rebecca Thomas from the
Independent you've talked about a
culture of denial
at the trust and Scandals exposed since
Morgan Bay you've just mentioned the
recommendations at Morgan Bay which
weren't answered
um which I haven't been
implemented do you believe we have a
culture of denial amongst the national
bodies
um who are overall responsible and do
you think there's been a failure in
Attitude Change from ministers and
policy makers which have led to these
subsequent scandals
I think that the recourse to reputation
management as a reason for limiting
information and for presenting
alternative information which is better
rebuttal it's sometimes called I think
that's pretty Universal I think that
applies to a great many bodies not just
in the public sector but particularly in
the public sector it's widespread I've
been Associated one way or another with
an awful lot of Investigations going
right back to the Hillsborough
independent panel and you would find
exactly the same thing happening on the
part of the police in West Yorkshire and
the ambulance service and and others I
think it's very very widespread and I
think the point of a public service is
accountability bill would be that it
would incorporate all of those it's not
something specific to the Health Service
thank you
Alison Moore from Health Service Journal
you mentioned accountability you say
that that lies with successive boards
and chief Executives who have the
evidence that there were problems and
intact on it
many of those individuals on on those
boards and indeed some of the chief
Executives still work within the NHS
they may not be regulated so they may
not be doctors or or nurses what should
happen to them
yeah
I think that uh the statutory
accountability for that lies with NHS
England I don't have the power to
make something happen I think that
failed I've set out where accountability
lies and what for
um and it is then up to people who have
the ability to do something about that
to hold those people accountable
the health secretary today won't be
reaching a statement to the commons
thank you
do you trust that she fully understands
the scale of change that you say needs
to happen and if so what conversations
have you had with the health secretary
that make you believe she fully
understands exactly the scale because
we're not going to see it in the
comments this afternoon okay thank you
for that
um
I uh have been very careful to make sure
that the families heard about the
investigation findings
first so I haven't they haven't been in
a position to see the report until it
was laid in Parliament a little while
ago
I have as I said earlier opened a
Channel of communication with both NHS
England and health ministers and on the
basis of what I was able to tell them at
that time they were certainly taking it
seriously what form that will take I
don't know but this certainly deserves a
formal response I expect it will get one
I'm disappointed that that isn't going
to be today but I will make sure that to
the best of my ability that it gets the
response that it deserves now they've
had a chance to read it
it's one for two more questions I've
asked one is there anyone else
okay yeah
um on that note we've just had a
response from the Department of Health
and Social care the health Minister Dr
Caroline Johnson said she's still
reading your report and she will make a
detailed response in time but what she
also says and it seems to be a current
theme with the departmental responses is
they're going to make 127 million pounds
available to grow the workforce and
improve neonatal care well money fix
this problem
um I I recognize that the service is
under strain and that people are working
under strain but that did not lie at the
root of the causes that we saw happening
in East Kent and if that were the only
it I have no doubt that it's necessary
and will be beneficial but if that were
the only thing that happened this would
not be sufficient to fix what happened
at East Kent that's why these four areas
for Action are absolutely vital and I
will be doing everything that I can to
continue with that dialogue and say it's
not enough in these circumstances
okay any of the questions for anyone
else
I'm sorry
hi
sorry um could I just clarify the
figures on maternal deaths and injuries
um because we've got the figure of 45
baby deaths
um do you know how many maternal deaths
could have been avoided
yeah I haven't set that out in quite the
same terms because it maternaled Us by
their nature are a rare event and it's
awfully easy for people to be identified
inadvertently if I refer to numbers
there there were 97 cases of harm injury
and death in total that includes 65 baby
babies who died
sorry that's not a veggie pardon I've
confused myself
97 cases of harm injury and death that
occurred that could have had a different
outcome had the proper standards been
applied there were 45
of baby deaths where there could have
been a different outcome had the same
standards being applied I'm sorry I've
slightly gone around the houses on that
because I've confused myself with my own
numbers it's in the report if you look
yeah just set out better than I just so
can we say the worm maternal deaths